(swoosh)
- Next up is Kathleen Tate.
Now Kathleen, she attended Sage Summit,
she came to my session,
and then when I was leaving
she drove into the airport.
She's a hardcore fan from Chicago.
She writes in to say,
"My fear is that I'm a social worker
"attempting to get into the fashion world.
"I get motivation from Evan's channel
"and now his book, Your One Word.
"Do you have advice on moving
from a part time entrepreneur
"to a full time entrepreneur?"
- Yeah, hey Kathleen.
I'm sorry I didn't give
you a ride to the airport,
but Evan Almighty, he rocked in Chicago.
He set the Windy City alive,
and I think some context around that.
I think we really have an opportunity.
You're in search of work.
Wow, what a great job you do.
Without you, the world would
be just a lesser place,
and people who do social work
should be valued by everybody,
and it creates great social cohesion.
We've talked before about
caring for the vulnerable,
so you walk it everyday.
Now I think if you want to get into things
like fashion, designer fashion,
actually you've got a great platform
in terms of your current job.
What I'd advocate you do is again,
you've got a big dream, it
could be around fashion,
and we love that,
you get inspired by
Evan, which is brilliant,
but you have got the platform where,
I hate to use that word,
but you could kind of moonlight
doing your current job
where you get an income
from being a social worker,
but use that, and use the
time at weekends and evenings
to start creating your big idea.
And you're probably
going to have a website
associated with that products, and design,
and maybe even start talking
to potential customers
and potential sort of
distributors and stuff life that,
and even a potential manufacturer.
So what would be a
really cool idea, right,
this would be it Kathleen,
and you got to promise you can do this,
we're going to do another of
these broadcasts in a year's time,
and you're going to come
on the channel and say,
"Evan, I'm now running a
designer fashion business
"with a million dollar turnover,
"and I did it because of that broadcast
"gave me the inspiration.
"And I spent six months
still being a social worker,
"but actually that gave
me the platform to build,"
even it's a few hundred thousand dollars,
that would be unbelievable
and totally amazing.
So I'd say with all these things,
kind of cut the elephant
down into little chunks.
You've got a great hopefully secure income
being a social worker.
Use that as a platform.
You're doing an amazing
job as a social worker.
Do some moonlighting in the
evenings and weekends to say,
"How am I going to use this platform
"to connect me with my dreams, my passion,
"which is all about fashion?"
and then build that business.
Go after it, build the business.
Fund it sensibly just
to kind of kick it off,
get some product sales,
then reimburse that in growth,
and then you'll find you've
got a business you love.
The only tough decision you've got
is when you stop being the social worker
and give your notice really,
and I would advocate
that you kind of jump off the diving board
once you've got your
business in a bit of momentum
and you believe in it, then you should go.
Now the other thing, right,
I got this great piece
of advice from someone,
oh wow, when I went off to,
it was a start up company at the time,
it was a company called
Oracle Technology Company.
Everybody knows 'em, but at
the time nobody knew 'em.
They were a no name company
and they were a startup.
And I was with a pretty
safe company at the time
and I went to my boss and said,
"Look, I got this offer from Oracle.
"They sound like a pretty
crazy American company,
"going to rule the world, big vision.
"They got this guy Larry
Ellison running 'em."
And I said, "I really am torn,
"because I've got a great
career here, pretty safe,
"but I think I would want to
risk an early stage company."
And he said, "The good thing is, Steven,"
he said, "If you leave and resign,
"you know the door is always open
"if you leave well and you
never burn your bridges,
"so actually there should be
no fear about your decision,
"because you're well
liked, you're trusted,
"you do a great job for us,
"but most of all you
should go and try that,
"and if it works out,
"you're going to be a
rainmaker somewhere else,
"but if it didn't work out,
"the door is always open here,
"and the only thing that
you might have to swallow
"is your pride.
"But you're a big guy.
"You're a grown up.
"That will be no problem for you."
Good advice.
So Kathleen, I'd love 2017 to be the year
where you make it happen
and you follow your dreams,
and you're an incredible brand
in terms of design and fashion.
That would be amazing.
- I like the one year
challenge to get to a million.
I love that.
And what did you say about
elephant, cutting it into chunks?
What was that expression?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
hey, oh, they say this.
Like they say, "Let's bring
the moose in the room,"
in Canada.
We say over in Europe,
"Let's get the elephant on the table."
But how do you eat an elephant?
You cut it into very small chunks,
break it into 2,000 chunks.
So when you're putting a
business plan together,
and you're going to be the biggest
designer fashion brand
on the planet, Kathleen,
you've got to break it into little chunks.
What do I want to do
for 90 days, 180 days?
And then you'll find momentum.
You'll find you have a following.
You'll find you'll have
raving fanatics as customers.
And you'll develop partners,
and hopefully all your employees
will be big brand ambassadors for you,
and then you got rolling
thunder, you got momentum,
but you have to kind of start small,
have a massive dream, big dream,
and just a phrase I use, yeah,
cut the elephant up in 1,000 chunks,
and then you can eat it and enjoy it.
- Eat the elephant one chunk at a time.
Alright, I like that.
- That's it.
I love it.
- I like that.
For people who are part time
trying to move full time,
I agree with Steven.
I would say you need to make sure
that you are spending time
every day on your business.
It's easy to get caught up in
your job and responsibilities,
and if you have kids,
life can get in the way
and then you never actually
got to do the thing
that is also supposedly important to you,
which is your business,
so make sure you're spending
time on it every single day,
even if it's half an hour,
like every day, something
to help your business grow.
And then try to figure out
where your skills are best used.
What's the highest value
that Kathleen can bring?
'Cause people will throw all
sorts of ideas at you, like,
"Kathleen, you got to get on YouTube!
"Kathleen, you got to be on Instagram!
"Kathleen, you got to
talk to this manufacturer!
"Kathleen, you got to go
to these presentations!"
whatever it is,
and you end up doing
everything in a mediocre way,
instead of one thing really, really right.
What's the highest use of Kathleen's time
that you can apply in those
30 to 60 to 90 to 120 minutes a day
to really make them count?
You figure that out, and
then you're on your way
to going from part time
to full time and beyond.
- Hey Kathleen, by the way,
Evan and I, we're pretty humble guys.
We're really happy to
do product placements
for really cool designer clothes
that you're going to create
over the next year or so.
So it would be pretty cool
to come on Evan's (mumbles),
and I guess Evan would love
to wear a Blue Jay shirt
or designer clothes created
and brilliantly inspired
and nurtured by Kathleen.
So we'll do product placements
for you, and we'll pump...
And the other thing, actually,
if you get going and
you follow your dreams,
what I love doing is pumping out
great ideas on social media,
so we'll give you all the help we can.
(swoosh)